i'ma say action action first and like to
introduce yourself my name is Bassam my
name is moses or and my cinema studies
and a 15 year old why do you leave a
little silver how are they doing for the
living
hey bruh
machi okay my name is Angela I've been
skating like turns six years seven years
and I think it's cool
so on John gappy sky top dollar
I skate at Cindy Kooskia camp with the
other guys yeah yeah y UT right Baba
when I give away right gotcha logos
footy in Colima single corner in a
Benghazi yellow male in God come on
O'Connor any male he put me with Supper
when Jesus gets pendulum novelty is Adam
cargo any massages ye more oh I got one
oona point footlong this thing is
important for me because yeah it's
important for for everybody because we
used to play here it was not completely
good because the children were playing
on the streets we were playing very
rough so we have collected every kids
that are playing on the yards and
streets that that could skate ads in the
Qashqai camp and I love it a lot
we come together all of the guys and
girls come together to be like a family
there are coaches that are coaching I'll
let say it mustn't do that somebody
doesn't like it okay and teach me to
respect someone like you respect you
yeah
and now
Oh
whoo-hoo-hoo magic tell me not playing
the role
Oh
Wow
Oh
my girls are getting away
I got escaped
Kotaku any competition inside gana
sakala life so was it just kids on their
younger coach amongst us kids so fight
and go right Susan doesn't know when you
want a bash
one language one color belong to
nobility
ha ha ha
Oh
fifteen tradition of this the mounted
mr. Chiu's but thanks for coming on this
is a lot of things once a year yes just
above yeah it's a brief rule anyone
could skate skate parks English about 25
26 years oh yeah let me choose to sleep
on my part like in down yo yo yo yeah
pull your sternum
three times in the bed
so we've got the longest one yeah
anyone know
London Marylebone we're gonna award a
union can be trophy or something that's
illogical jamun not to open number that
no job baby
yeah
what is Eliza Naumann Vanderloo no any
trip Eldersburg place you've got teary
Charlotte yeah
we asking for us because we want to live
a life which is good and awesome
Hey
yeah cool can't